let's uh let's talk about stupidity
because I know you're against it I've
heard you speak out against it many
times I am against it yeah at the same
time I don't think the world would work
without it well you know everything
would have to change yes right because
it's quite clear to me now at my grand
old age is 75
oh no yep don't you love the thank you
you're alive you're alive
here I'm great
what could you raise yes where were we
oh you were up you were remembering at
your old age at my old age something
that I forgot well you know what the
great I was gonna say to you about age
the great thing about it as I said this
to Jerry Seinfeld who is on our show a
few months ago and he just turned 60 and
I said when you passed like 60 you have
a license to be cranky about it you know
yeah you just don't buddy holds it
against you anymore I find that oh but
comedy is about things not being right
right now things are running beautifully
and everyone's behaving appropriate
intelligently is nothing funny that's no
good it's all about people being stupid
and it's all about the things going
wrong and screwing up so you you either
point that out with sort of anger like
Lenny Bruce would have done right or
else you pointed out cuz it kind of gets
funny and what I realized at 75 now is
that almost nobody has any idea what
they're talking about right look we do
agree yeah absolutely but what do you
treat fans I mean you're you're loudly
badly I mean it you're allowed to be an
[ __ ] right if they want a picture
with you warning creatures mmm
Oh wonderful I am and how can I be a
wonderful as you [ __ ] off that's what I
be yeah okay
now in this country we call that being
politically incorrect oh really
yes which is the name of my first job
yeah yeah I used to watch and uh you
know political incorrect is could we
just [ __ ] about that fro awful isn't it
it starts out as a half way of halfway
decent idea right and then it goes
completely wrong right akin to an absurd
I used to go out and do these racial
jokes I'd say French you know why do the
French have so many civil wars so they
can win one now and again why are why
are Australians so well balanced cuz
they have a chip on each shoulder you
know I used to do these jokes and then I
say and that there were these two
Mexicans and the whole place would go
home right I want to say what what you
make jokes about Swedes and Germans and
French and English and Canadians and
Americans I can't be make jokes about
Mexicans is it because they're so feeble
that they can't look after the sushi
it's very very condescending there you
know well why is it what are the people
can't make jokes about Muslims Muslim
yeah try that Kevin let's see what your
Twitter feed says yes yeah but that's
not saying that you can't know oh
they'll tell you [ __ ] right my what yes
oh yes I said that theoretically you
know I've made jokes like you know it's
a religion of peace there's a PC over
there there's a PC over there and see
they're there pretending to laugh now
but you can tell their first instinct
was oh no you didn't you know oh dear
that's terribly important but the
problem is if you make jokes about
people are going to kill you there is a
sort of a tendency to hold back a little
isn't there yeah just a little but I
mean I I think any kind of
fundamentalism is terribly funny because
all you know the thing about
fundamentalism is it's taking whatever
the book is the Koran or the Bible for
absolutely literal right now I've met
some pretty pretty smart people in my
life you know not a single one of them
was literal-minded right right that's
absolutely so do we write it so do we
say well Jesus said these things but of
course Jesus was very very
literal-minded so he would want these
things to be interpreted absolutely
literally no no he was smarter than that
and this is a basic understand mission
well if you're going to take anybody
literally I would take him literally
because he was a promoter of peace yes
yes oh he could be cranky too when he
threw the money lenders out of the
temple right and he said things like if
you don't come to God through me you
will burn which is cranky but that's but
in general he's nicer Holy's nice Oh